a 401k is an employer-sponsored
retirement plan
why is it called a 401k well that's the
section of the internal revenue code for
the federal government that allows you
to do it now what are the benefits well
as far as i know there's two major ones
the biggest one is it allows you to save
money for retirement before taxes
so normally you get a paycheck you have
to pay some taxes on that money and then
you get the money and then you might be
able to invest it if you're able to save
some of it but with the 401k you get to
put your pre-tax money in before taxes
are taken out and put that into an
investment account for retirement
now
there's a little bit of a catch because
you can invest it tax-free in a 401k
account
but then when you take it out when you
retire at age older than 59 and a half
you will then have to pay taxes so your
taxes are deferred now that might work
out because at that time you're retired
that might be all of your income you
might have a lower tax rate then or at
minimum you were able to at least defer
the taxes and invest without having to
pay them
now the other benefit of a 401k is many
employers will match or do a partial
match of some of the money that you
contribute so some might say for every
dollar you put in what 50 cents or for
every dollar we'll put a dollar up to a
certain amount so by putting money into
a 401k you're to some degree able to get
free money from your employer
now there is a catch if you were to take
that money out before your 59 and a half
or there's some other special cases
you're going to have to pay a penalty of
about or exactly 10 percent
of what you take out so it isn't
something that you want to do lightly
but in a lot of cases because of the
employer match it still might be okay to
do it because once again you're getting
that free money from the employer